let's say a very good morning then to
Rachel Reeves and what about that
proposal always thinking about it anyway
from Ian Duncan Smith about banning EU
migrants from accessing benefits here
for up to two years well first of all
the majority of EU migrants who come to
this country come here to work and they
work incredibly hard and contribute to
our economy but it's also right that we
protect our social security system and
our public services from any abuse and
that's why I'd Miliband and the vet
Cooper said in March last year that
there should be restrictions about when
you migrants can claim benefits and in
December last year in Duncan Smith
announced that that would be after three
months and we very much supported that
to get further change it need change to
EU treaties but we are in favor of the
government working with other European
countries to put in place those further
restrictions whether it be to child
benefit three months to two years is
something you would go along with I mean
we understand you were getting for every
parcels yet from the government he said
one to two years in that interview with
the sunday time it seems to have rode
back a little bit from that this morning
but they come up with concrete proposals
that are workable that are practical
that protects our social security system
that protects that principle that you
have to pay something in before you get
something out then we would support